the network's in 20 good morning and
yeah I'm glad to be here so I think the
main goal for me for fruit for this
period of time is to just sort of share
our perspective which is just sort of a
point of view that has sort of
definitely shaped the way I think about
things and it basically boils down to
this which is the quantum computation is
the same thing as approximating sensor
networks
and by the same thing I really mean the
same thing there's an equivalence
between them to make that sort of very
explicit which I'll do later I have to
tell you what level of which I'm
approximating but that's that's the
basic picture and this is a sort of it
has helped certainly helped me in a lot
of ways to sort of sort of think about
problems differently and sort of
understand quantum mechanics which I
don't pretend to understand and all
those sorts of things so and just sort
of so this is the result but it kind of
leads to a point of view which is which
I think most of you actually already
have in either implicit or explicit ways
but that the time in a sort of quantum
computation setting is really just
geometry or you can sort of replace it
by geometry and this this idea of a
unitary map our unitary evolution is
really gets replaced just by linear Maps
and the other part of this perspective
that I that but at least I find helpful
is that it kind of provides a sort of
unifying platform to sort of think about
these quantum questions and also think
about classical simulation and I'll try
to touch upon that and all I think most
of these things elements of them have
been seen in various talks this week and
I wouldn't be surprised if a lot of you
come away from this saying oh yeah I
knew that so but we'll see so let's see
okay so so and I'm going to sort of
finish off with a an open question that
I've had for quite a while that at least
in this picture is certainly interesting
for me and I think it might be something
that some of you may have something to
say about so that's the that's the plan
so let's see I'm going to just start by
sort of saying what i mean by tensors
and by tensor networks just so that
we're all on the same page so I think we
can probably go through this quickly but
of course definitely stop me if
something seems wrong or not quite your
intuition or not quite how you're used
to thinking about it so for me a tensor
is going to be a picture like this okay
with so it's a sort of blob maybe it's a
label blob with some edges coming out of
it right and the edges take on labels so
each edge can have be labeled and we're
thinking of the labels as a as a you
know basis for a standard basis for a
some dimensional space so I'll even use
this notation for the labels right and
then if I actually label everybody any
time for any set of labels that I label
anybody if I label all the edges by
something
out spits out a number for example all
right so okay everybody knows tensors in
a different way is one way to say this
is this an array of numbers it's a
multi-dimensional array their various
other things this is just an encoding of
that statement all right so as long as I
label all the edges the thing that pops
out is a number so um so that's a tensor
and the value of sort of writing it as a
picture is that you can simultaneously
view it as different interpretation so
the one interpretation is as a vector
and so for simplicity for now I'm going
to say I guess that there are d labels
and I'm going to have every edge have D
labels but in general you could have
different edges can have it being
allowed to contain different numbers of
labels and but if it was uh d labels
then mi could view I could view this
tensor em as a vector in where well in
CD each one of these edges cancer
however many times the degree is which
is in this case 1 2 3 4 5 okay and what
is the vector that it is well I just
write out in the standard basis and the
coefficient I put in front of i1 i2 up
to i-5 is what I would get if I labeled
the first edge I pick some ordering of
the edges if I label the first stage by
able I won the second x to the 3rd by 3
to the fourth I 04 and so what I would
stake here would be the in the 0 2 to 4
3 coefficient would be point seven okay
but the but the but the point of this is
that also there are other
interpretations for this tensor and the
other interpretations are as a whole
vast a whole number of linear maps
okay and as linear Maps what I'm going
to do is I'm going to interpret I'm
going to sort of i'm going to split the
edges into two sets okay so suppose I
sort of single out these two edges all
right and in this case if I've singled
out these two edges I'm going to view em
as a map from two copies of C to the
remaining three copies of C D sorry GD
this sort of locals space and how am I
going to define this map well if I can
tell you what it does on a basis on the
basis element of C D so I'm going to
tell you what it does on I 1 I 2 well
it's going to send it to some sum over I
three i-4 i-5 right and what's the
coefficient here going to be well you
guessed it it's going to be I label
these two edges by i1 i2 these three by
three or four or five out pops a number
again right and so in this case the
component of 03 an M takes 03 to a sum
of all kinds of things and the component
in the two to four thing is going to be
point set okay now so so this this sort
of so you may have seen tensors in
different forms where you talk about
covariant and contravariant sort of
pieces to them which means sort of you
kind of specify which are the input
edges and which are the output edges and
then you worry about conjugation and
things like that I'm not going to do any
of that I'm going to serve it's not
really sweeping it under the rug this is
going to be my convention this is how
I'm going to interpret things and so if
you do want to make covariant and
contravariant you may have to take
conjugates here and there to do what you
need to do okay is that is that clear
okay okay so I've got tensors and what
are they good for well I want to sort of
just I want to sort of manipulate them
all right and so I want to do a various
operations I'm use individual pictures
all right i want to sort of understand
what I'm going to sort of drawers new
pictures from old pictures and I want to
make sure we all know what they mean and
so they're just only two operations the
first is that I can stick to different
tensors on the same picture all right so
this was maybe 1 tensor and this is
another tensor and what I'm what I'm
going to tell you is this is this that
I'm going to interpret this as a third
tensor and the way I'm going to do it is
i'm just going to instead of using this
little black circle on that black circle
I'm going to sort of take a bigger
circle like that and i'm going to view
it as something with 77 edges coming out
and now I have to if I'm going to view
this it's a tensor I have to tell you
what number comes out when I label all
these guys so if I label all these guys
I go back to this picture that has all
these guys labeled which means this
represents a number and this represents
the number and the number i'm going to
associate with this guy is the product
of the two example okay and what is this
correspond to well when I'm talking
about when I think of at these
individual guys's vectors this
corresponds to tensor product okay so
this is tensor product when tensors are
thought of as vectors okay so that's
that's this operation product and then
there's the second operation which is
contraction okay and the second
operation so again I'm going to sort of
give you a picture and I'm going to tell
you how to interpret that picture as a
tensor so let's say I have this guy
again and this guy but now what I'm
going to do is I'm going to join two of
the edges okay so mm okay so now if I do
my same thing of sort of drawing a
little box that a little bold that
capsule eights all the stuff that
doesn't have stuff and make sure
everything still has stuff coming out
what I see it is is a picture with well
five things coming out all right so I
want to view this as a tensor so what do
I need to do is if you label all these
guys I have to tell you what number
should come out right so label all these
guys what happens well we get all these
guys labeled but we don't get this guy
labeled right if I specify a label
hearing is that gets everything here
right and what I say that this is equal
to is the sum over all possible labels
of this guy okay so if for any
particular labeling of this guy now
everything is labeled okay and I've got
one number here one numbered here i
multiply those two numbers together
right and then i sum over
all possible laborers into Central Penn
right and so this is this is contraction
and so this is another way of taking two
tensors and producing a third one okay
so with this setup right now there's
meaning to pictures like this they don't
need to be planar hopefully I didn't
and then if this would be a man p et
cetera okay so and maybe I have some
just coming out you don't okay any
picture like that has meaning right
because it's a what how did I get such a
picture like that well there are many
different ways I could have gotten it
using these two operations depending on
the order right one way is I could have
plopped down each of these guys as
individual guys first and then started
joining things up another ways I could
have just plopped down the first two
guys join them up the way they wanted to
pop down the second one join those oh
but the beauty of sort of this notation
is that it doesn't matter what order I
do it if you do the calculation as to
what it is that this is supposed to mean
it all means the same thing and if you
want to figure out what it means is you
draw a big circle around the whole thing
that gives you that it's a some sort of
tensor depending on how many lines are
coming out of the circle how many free
edges there are as soon as you label the
free edges you have to tell me what
number comes out and what number comes
out is a sum over all possible internal
labelings so it's a massive sum now
right it's a sum over you take the you
sum over all possible internal labelings
for each internal set of labelings right
there's a number pops out for each of
these tensors you multiply those numbers
together and then you do this massive
sum okay so encapsulated in this kind of
network is a massive sum right some of
how many terms well it's exponential in
the the you know it's D to the power of
the number of non-free edges okay so all
right so I'm probably not hitting
anything that you haven't thought about
in some way or another oh this is an
interesting feature of having a hole in
your pocket hmm what maybe like this
what do you think we'll see what happens
that's okay okay the number of free
strands coming out of my pocket
okay so so okay so this is basically so
the way I think of this is basically a
graphical sort of picture of linear
algebra so this is sort of there's
various familiar things and so for I
guess everybody knows this but I'll sort
of do it anyway so a picture like this
right I I want to sort of have a picture
of what that means in sort of the world
that I'm used to living in which made me
not be tensor networks right so a
picture like this this turns out if you
sort of figure out what it is it's the
sum over this so what if I interpret am
as a as a vector and as a vector right
this becomes the inner product of eminem
and maybe you have to put a conjugate on
one of them okay like because i sum over
internal labelings and then i have a
product of things so this is another
product and so would a picture like this
if i had two guys and they're joined up
by many strands still same picture right
i can tear of take this break it into i
can think of the bottom as a vector the
top of the vector and the thing is an
inner product right and this is not this
is not sort of vague schematic like you
know things this is precise right this
is actually the inner product when you
think of these things affect okay and so
that we've also got a you know maybe a
picture like this and I want to sort of
this is sort of the classic contraction
picture okay and I can sort of say well
how do I understand this tensor well let
me think of em as a map from this from
here to here a linear map or a matrix
from here to here okay and I don't think
of n as a matrix from here to here right
then what this picture turns out to be
is matrix product right this is the
composition of two linear Maps this is
the map M followed button depending on
whether you have left or right whichever
way M times X this is M times M okay and
so more complicated pictures right they
do that and then like that and then have
a sort of picture like this going on
but this doesn't specify the dimensions
this uh I haven't specified the
dimensions so the picture is not exactly
are you doing other sizes using all the
order of the products well let's um so
so let's see so if we if we imagine that
each of these edges has a thickness
associated to it that would be fine like
the number the meaning the number of
labels it absorbs but there are also
these yeah so this would be a map from
whatever dimensions face this is to
whatever dimension is a stud and so all
we make sure is so maybe that's that i
should say thats all right though i was
restricting to the case where they're
all the same dimension if i change the
dimensions then in my contraction set up
I have to make sure that I only join
things that are at the same dimension
okay and so a picture like this right if
I sort of cut it here I can see the top
part of the picture as a tensor right
but I'll think of it as a linear map
from these guys to these guys and the
bottom guy is a linear map from these
guys to these guys and this is
composition of those two events
okay and so with this point of view now
this takes on much more rich meeting
right so i can think of this this is a
tensor right this is a tensor okay but i
can think of it as being formed by some
series of operations consisting of
linear maps or inner products or various
other things yeah how do you represent
the trees from a good question good
question so you're not a plant are you
okay so not not a plant up case we'll
explore not for the non-native plants
meeting some you know a magician plants
somebody in the audience that it's not
not the growing type of okay so actually
let's start first by saying what's the
trade so if I have em as a matrix M is a
tensor but I'm going to interpret it as
a matrix let's pretend these guys at the
same dimension how do i write down the
trace of that matrix well that's just
the sum of the diagonal elements I want
the top guy to be the same as the bottom
guy and so the way I do that is this all
right so this is the trace of em ok so
the trace of a product looks like this
and now I don't know this is the best
proof I I know of the trace of MND
cooling the trace of antenna right
because once you have this right what do
you do you take this guy you bring it
down you bring it around now it's an end
but it's upside down once it's over here
ah ok which looks like a you I guess and
then you keep going you keep going it's
up here and now it's on the side and you
by the time you're done you get it up
here and it's back to its normal
position right and now I interpret this
picture and this is the trace of in it
but if you stretch the right like the
long leg and make this right yeah the
one that those are ya you can't form a
picture that looks like a rank to
contraction
Spencer's Frank to the track so what do
we do here what did you want to go what
all the heck stumbled I mean so it
doesn't really be this but I think it's
ok sorry if you have this NM of an edge
yet they have eminent ok I don't have an
inch there's a man here now yeah then
you have another edge that's not
straight but also connects Emmett this
one yeah but you can make it straight
then it looks like a rag to contraction
right looking at the top right picture
you have top right so yeah if you race
10 guys that is it located that's crazy
yeah so you could so you could you could
rewrite this as this this picture is
this what your Chinese I think and that
picture is that what your kind of is
that you're safe and then we could sort
of think of it as so I'm saying is that
the right hand top you know if you
delete one of those edges where your
finger is is the same picture yeah okay
yeah and that's true until this weekend
that turns out to be the same relation
initially
okay so all right so we're all set with
that okay so now what is a tensor
network well the tensor network is a
picture like this like the one I drew
okay it's just a collection of tensors
some of which are joined some of which
are not
okay so a tensor network is a picture
like this we have lots of tensors and
things and will will pretty much focus
though not completely okay so actually
so let me just say what a close tensor
network is so what else what I'm just
calling a closed tensor network is a
network like that with no free edges
okay so everybody's join to something
right and so a tensor network or
foreclosed tensor network has no free
edges and what does that turn out to be
that turns out to be a number so close
to answer networks are numbered open
cancer networks we can interpret them as
different cancel okay okay so remember
sort of this this you know this is where
I'm going for right which is the quantum
computation is the same as approximating
tensor networks so let me start with a
motivating example which is how to view
a quantum computation as a tensor
network okay and this is pretty
straightforward but let me
do it unless
okay so what's the quantum computation
right so you start by initializing some
thing in a set of zeros let's say and
I'm going to draw a circuit picture of
this thing and now I start to apply some
unitary gates and I do that for a while
buying my unitary gates local and
eventually
what do I do is I
I measure the first qubit or queued it
okay and I see when how often I get 0
and how often I get one and I use that
as my computation okay so I want to view
this as a tensor network so how do I
view this as a tensor network well very
simply it's almost it's almost there by
itself right so these guys I want to
think of this initializing in zero I
want to think of as a tensor so I'm
going to define a particular little
small tensor that I'll call 0 actually
i'll call it zero without the thing on
it zero all right and the 0-10 sir will
be such that if you label this x 0 you
get out you spits out a 1 and if you
label it by anything else that spits out
a zero okay alright so here I'm going to
start out so now at this point if I if I
lay these the same tents are over and
over and over again and I look at what I
have right now I have a vector and that
vector is the all zeros vector just like
I would have had at the beginning of the
computation right and now i'm going to
apply some unit Ares while the unit Ares
I just apply unitary Tsar just i'm going
to write down the tensors that
correspond to the unit arias thinking of
the tensors as linear maps right so i
sort of these squares become circles
okay but never mind right and by the
time I'm done down here before I've done
measurement right I have if I draw my
big red picture the grid if i look at
this is now a network and if i look at
this network it's got a bunch of edges
coming out the bottom and if i interpret
that as a vector i'm going to have
exactly the state i have here before
I've measured ok ok so now if I want to
know the probability of so what do I
have here right I have at this point I
have some vector sign ok and I want and
I end up writing sigh as equal to size 0
plus I one where size zero is the
component of side that has zero as its
first thanks to my right thigh it well
maybe I'll do it to say
like this okay so this is the I
decompose sigh into its peace with zero
in the first coordinate is peace with 1
i'm now assuming these are cubits okay
and my probability of getting zero is
what it's the absolute value it's the
norm of square root of sizer that's the
probability of getting zero my outcome
being zero right so suppose so when I do
a computation right and I do it may be
multiple times or I do it once right
what do I get out I get out you know I
get out a sample from the distribution
size 0 squared inside 1 squared all
right so i get an approximation for for
this value they do it multiple times i
get a better approximation well right
now I've got this vector Phi right here
yeah so so so size zero and sigh one
live on this is they live on this space
and I just decomposed it in terms of
women as it but then the probability
said is the normal death vector not
random yeah so the probability that
might if i measure the first qubit and
probability good showing up zero is the
norm of the sector swear this is an
orthogonal decomposition the sum of the
squares is one and the probability of my
dreams zero will show up with
probability the size of this thing
square one will show up with the sides
of it
okay okay so this is the number that you
know the computation sort of
approximates or 1 minus that number
whichever way you want to do and right
now I'm sitting here at sigh okay so now
if I just add the tensor if I put in the
tensor zero down here what does that
cancer do that tensor int that tensor
just sort of pics out size zero and if I
put this here the resulting thing so
before I had sigh coming out right I had
something that looked like sigh and now
I put a 0 here 0 tensor what's left I'll
leave you to verify that this picture is
equal to society 0 okay so this is sy 0
how how can I write down a picture that
gets to me the norm squared of size zero
well it's a vector I want its norm
squared I enter product with itself
right so what do I want to do is I want
to take this whole picture pick it up
turn it over put in conjugates and put
it on itself so let me not draw that to
draw some schematic version of that
I've got these zeros then I'm going to
sort of encode the rest of the circuit
by MC then I stick in the zero here what
I'm left with is what I called size zero
now i'm going to pick that picture up
turn it over and inner product it with
itself
okay and what do I get out of this again
exactly out the probability of showing
up 0 this is equal to the probability of
measuring 0 in the first in first okay
okay so here's the tensor network that
encodes the quantum computation Thanks
so what have I done so far I've showed
that any quantum computation can be seen
as approximating a particular sensor
network right and what's the form of the
sensor network will you start out and
then you use unit areas in the maybe
your level and protection right at the
end and so it seems like a very specific
class but what I'm now going to show you
is that in fact let's not worry about
its structure because we can we can
reverse this process as long as we
define what we mean by approximating
okay and let me just sort of say quickly
what i mean by approximating here if you
want to approximate you know one one
time doing this right just gives you a
sample from a distribution that's
weighted size zero squared so i 1
squared if I allowed to do this
polynomial number of times I get a
polynomial approximation to this guy so
what is it so the the the value of this
tensor network is exactly 50 squared and
what does the quantum computation does
it give me an approximation up to 1 over
a poly of that value
in here in this case it's yeah I guess
there's no no but I'm also saying is
that the bottom thing gives an additive
approximation to this number sampling is
an a difference which I guess needs to
be stressed for what what happens they
ok so now ok so what do we want to do we
want to take this as inspiration right
to do the up to do the reverse and
what's the reverse right the reverse is
starting with any network
all right and using designing the
quantum algorithm for computing it sad
and okay so what's so what are the
components that are needed so quantum
algorithm or approximating tensor
network okay the first thing I'm going
to do is I'm going to pick up what we'll
call a bubbling which is just an order
ring have the tensors okay so I'm going
to pick an ordering of the tensors so
let me take this order this is the first
this is the second this is the third
this is the fourth this is the fifth
this is the six mysticism physically
some more constraints or something yeah
no I mean the approximation is going to
absorb the norm constraint okay so what
do I want to do is I'm going to so
here's the here's the idea of what
bubbling looks like bubbling is I'm
going to imagine that I have this bubble
that starts to swallow the network okay
so it's like this big red blob and at
first it comes on the outside and the
first thing it's going to do is it's
going to swallow this that's the first
vertex the second thing it's going to do
is it's going to move over here and it's
going to swap so that's what a bubbling
looks like and the that sort of gives
you a sort of picture of how I'm going
to interpret each of these tensors so
the first tensor that it swallows I'm
going to interpret just that as the
easiest way to think of it is that
that's some vector that I'm starting
helping and then the next one
is going to be like this okay and what
I'm going to do is to say how i got from
here to here i'm going to interpret this
i'm going to now use my tensor network
interpretation to say you know what I'm
going to get from here to here by
applying this tensor but as a linear map
from the guys that are touched
beforehand which is this one to all the
ones that are touched by the time I'm
done which are these three so I'm going
to view this tensor is a linear map from
the ones touched before to the ones to
blunt that weren't touched before and
I'm going to keep going so now for 3 i'm
going to view it as a linear mouth from
these two because these two have already
been touched to the following three etc
etc so what I'm going to first do is so
you see this map as a sequence of events
which is starting with a vector then
applying linear maps and if you'd like
the last one can either be in a product
with another vector or applying a linear
map that's I you know that let's not
worry about the last one makes was just
going to be kanga leopard words yeah so
let's let's yeah let's keep so yeah so
may I that's a good point so the tensor
network I should have said the let's say
every tensor has bounded degree of
sometimes constant degree I guess would
be helpful for what I'm gonna say
yeah you could though you might worry
that different trade compositions with
different levels of the prices yeah but
yes you could okay as long as you had
the ability to do that in time that you
have okay alright so now so do people
see sort of what I'm trying to do is I'm
trying to sort of the vector that i'm
starting with I'm going to try to make
it look like this and then the linear
maps I'm trying to try to do this stuff
now you'll notice something important
which is those linear maps all need to
be unitary right there's no need for any
of these maps to be unitary right so
there are two things I have to sort of
keep track of
so this is the these are not unitary
these these maneuvers right so let's
talk about this any particular map so
does everybody understand the sequence
of events I'm once I bubbled the thing I
consider see it as starting with a
vector and moving by linear maps to the
end and the result of that computation
whatever that is that's the value of the
tensor now right and so now I'm going to
sort of so let's aim at let's sort of
look at any one of these maps let's look
at this map a all right so this is the
this a is not necessarily unitary so
there's let's deal with the first
problem which is that it may have
operator norm greater than 1 but i can
compute what its operator norm is it's a
small pen sir right so what I'm going to
do is I'm going to keep that information
on the side so i'm going to replace a
with a over the norma bay and in doing
so I've now at least made a norm one
it's not unitary but its norm one ok and
I'm going to keep track of I'm going to
hold on the side all those a's so I'm
going to keep track over here ok the
product of the norms of all the A's ok
so now I'm going to pretend that it
actually the picture that I had was a
over norm a which had norm one hey and
by the time I'm done I know that I have
to scale everything back up by this much
right so I'm going to sort of instead of
doing this tensor network I'm gonna do
the normalized version of this network
i'm going to replace every tensor by
eight mahavir its norm when i was
thinking of it in this particular
ordering and i'm going to approximate
that one and if i get an approximation
of that one that will translate once i
scale to an approximation of the other
one because they're related by this this
factor ok but i still got a problem
which is a has norm less than or equal
to one now or
actually equal to one right but it's not
unitary right so what do I do about that
well I do something pretty simple and
standard which is I embed it in a
unitary that's slightly bigger
and so there's so fight i'm going to i
started with an a let's now pretend that
a is normalized already so if you look
at this map you get the
alright this
is unitary so for any norm less than or
equal to one thing if you sort of form
this slightly bigger matrix ever you
want to map right that's unitary and
this is this is just a kid to say if
they just think of this as if you had a
real number that was less than one and
you wanted to sort of make put it as the
upper left-hand corner of a unitary you
just use a rotation where that number
sat in the upper left-hand corner right
so this is like sine cosine minus cosine
sine this is the exact same thing it's
just then I'm pretty alright and so
pictorially what this is saying is
notice that the you know the upper left
hand corner of this thing is a and so
pictorially this is this fact and if I
take you which now has two indices on
top and bottom and I restrict by putting
a 0 here and a 0 here which says if I do
that I put those tensors on the end what
am i doing I'm picking out the top left
corner ok so this picture equals
pictorially this is what it is it's a
any operator of norm less than or equal
to 1 can be written as a unitary on one
more qubit where I now squeeze that
extra index pacer ok so now I'm in good
shape right because I was complaining
before that these operators are not
unitary well I can throw in an extra you
know I can put in a picture like this
instead of a picture like that I put it
in a picture like that and so now what
do I have is I have the same pictures oh
but I've got some some guys sticking
there's some zeros on the top and on
bottom I pick up all the zeros that grow
up towards the top and so this picture
which before let's call it t right once
I make these trance once I make this
transformation it looks like a sort of T
Prime with a bunch of zeros sticking up
and down and let me yank them all the
ones that were going up up and all the
ones down down ok and what I've got left
inside is a unitary evolution ok so now
I can actually do this with a quantum
circuit right and all I'm left so I've
now got this sort of vector so I can
evolve up until here and the only thing
I have left to do is finally with my you
know I've so far I've done by a quantum
computer I've evolved to have this
there's a tensor right down here and I
have that tensor in my hand I want to
inner product it with the all zeros
vector right there's this involving the
swap test this is a simple a simple
thing to do so is it there's a unitary
you know there's a quantum algorithm for
taking a vector and inner product in it
to the all 0 Specter it's very simple
and I think I'll just sweep that under
the rug for the moment just it's not
worth 20 time so let's see what I've got
after all I've done right what I got
once I do this clown thing is an
approximation right I so now my quantum
algorithm what happens is I have success
in the quantum algorithm exactly
proportional to the value of this
network
but the value of this network right was
a scaled version of the value of the
original Network right so what I got was
a quantum algorithm that approximated so
this is my quantum algorithm you came up
with a value which is its success
probability and this is a one over
polynomial approximation to not the
original tension I work but the tensor
network over Delta where Delta was the
side factor of keeping track of all
these norms okay and so what this means
is now I if I sort of multiply through
by Delta right i can give an
approximation I use my value of Q and
multiply it by delta t minus that as an
approximation at the approximation level
delta x delta / poly yet so that's for
delta if I'm pulling out a factor of two
every time that's a pretty poor
approximation sort of you know it's one
over poly times 2 to the end okay well
it is what it is all right and it turns
out that not only is it a poor
approximation but it's the best that a
quantum computer can do and it's all
that economy computer to do this is a
complete problem as stated right so even
though that a level of approximation
isn't particularly impressive it's all
you can hope for out of the power of
quantum computation
sure yeah okay so you may ask there's
certain questions to ask and then let me
just sort of touch on how this point of
view sort of shapes other things so the
first thing to sort of point out is
bubbling does matter okay I can choose
one bubbling and I get one Delta I can
choose another bubbling and I get a
different dumpin so bubbling does matter
okay and finding the best bubbling is
not is provably hard so if you're trying
to do this for if you're trying to
design this for a certain thing you want
to use heuristics to try to find good
both links the second thing to say it's
uh I think it's at least attempt er yeah
that's because this is I mean it's it's
bubbling in a sense of minimizing the
phone yeah so the other thing that you
can try to do is take this tensor
network and replace it by a comparable
one right I could sort of say well maybe
there's a there's a decomposition of
this map in the clever way that sort of
now I've split this tensor into two
tensors in an interesting way and and
and that does yield some success you can
hope to do that and improve your levels
of approximation I should have said at
the beginning of this this is work with
a tire rod now let me sort of touch on
where this goes so with this point of
view here's here's what happened so this
point of view sort of basically says
look any problem that sort of has a
graphical picture associated to it is
something that I can sort of now do upon
them algorithm four I'll get some level
of approximation and that's exactly what
was done with the various that another I
guess there's some people call them sort
of these topological quantum algorithms
I don't know but anyway so there's sort
of there's a there's these quantum
algorithms for approximating the Jones
polynomial or the polynomial
and there's some quantum field theory
stuff so all these things this is the
this is the framework you should see all
those in right all these they say they
take these objects and there's some way
of looking at them for which these guys
aren't too bad and that's the whole
picture so for the Jones polynomial for
instance you for those of you who don't
know it's a sort of topological you know
if you have if you have a braid and you
want to understand whether two braids
are similar you're looking for in
variance of the braids the drums
polynomial is some such of such an
object and the way the scheme works is
you find a representation of the braids
group and which means sort of sticking
it in as linear algebra and what that
translates to is that you can sort of
turn these into tensors there's a
representation for which these are
tensors that their linear you know a
crossing is a linear map right and now
you just figure out the right way to
swallow the right way to bubble this
thing and you're all set and the focus
on certain roots of unity is because in
those cases these things are unitary
these crossings so let's see I'm running
out of time but let me sort of just say
sort of bring us back to this time
geometry or unitary linear map so the
unitary linear map is sort of pretty
clear the time geometry when I won't
just want to sort of say in the
following way right which is that I'll
just I'll just say it is this result
which sort of came at some point which
was sort of surprising at least at the
time to some people was that log depth
quantum circuits are classically
simulate able
I don't know if simulate able is a word
okay so okay so there is sort of a lot
of different ways that people i think
some of people realize this at this
virtually the same time but here's the
picture right so let me view the quantum
circuit as a tensor network okay and
what l'objet means is that the number
you know so I've got this sort of stuff
going on with the amount before I'm done
you know and then I do a measurement
here I can just sort of say is 20 but
this is log Mike again this is like that
so
so we know that the probability of this
involves just sticking this thing and
putting it upside down right and doing
that so this is the network we're trying
to evaluate how do we do this
classically okay well quantumly we were
kind of going this way classically we
just swallow this network this way okay
if you swallowed this network this way
you sort of start to bubble it this way
think of what at any stage what a
bumbling line how many free edges of
bubbling line crosses and how many
things are sticking out here you have to
kind of weave your way around these you
know the only place where you sort of
going to see a crossing right is sorry I
should keep should have been here it so
as I come down this the only place i
have to sort of move out of the way is
when it when there's an actual operator
sitting right here all right and then I
kind of have to bump out of the way and
I hit two edges so the number of edges
that are going to be sort of cut by this
line is just twice at most twice login
okay so what I'm looking at is trying to
keep track of a tensor with twice log n
edges coming up right each of these are
dimensioned d what size face is this
this is sized face d to the log in or do
the tool again which is a polynomial
size face I can do that classically just
do it keep track of the thing and now I
do linear algebra on this polynomial
size space keep-keep sort of edging my
way across pushing pushing things so
that it's pretty much up right right and
I by the time I'm done I'm done I'm my
way at the end so I'm back to a number
the number is the value of this tensor
it's the exact height so log get condom
circuits plastically i can compute
exactly right and it's the same reason
why but this is its points out the same
thing that goes on with matrix product
states that make
1d so different from 2d right is matrix
product States there's an arrow
direction if I look at what's going on
when I'm doing linear algebra there's an
arrow direction for Trudy there's no
narrow direction anymore right so if I
have a matrix if I want to compute the
inner product of two matrix product
states right all i do is classically i
swallow it this way I mean you know
they're slightly more efficient ways to
do it if you want to program it up but
this is the spirit of what's happening
right I'm going across this way instead
of coming down that way right into D
this is the peps right where you've got
a sort of 2d lattice and you're doing
inner products of two different peps
there's no longer such you know so now
you've got sort of two combs that are
sitting on top of each other now you
can't sweep through it in any way so
that it's narrow in one drag it's not
narrow all right no matter how you sweep
over you take a cut in the middle you're
going to cross at least end things iron
to exponential yeah this log in depth
local circuit physically local meaning
neighboring neighborhood yeah that's
important okay so I have time just to
say my open question okay so here's my
open question suppose I give you a
cancer network that I want to
approximate
with the condition that all the tensors
in the tensor network okay so here's the
extra condition i'm going to put all the
tensors have non negative entries okay
so each one of these sensors is an array
it's all non-negative numbers another
question is how so quantumly we have an
algorithm right it's specified this way
it's just it's just an example of a
tensor network so quantumly we know we
can approximate it to some level right
and the question is what can you do
possibly can you do the same thing can
you achieve that level of approximation
now okay here's here's the reason why
you should reason why you should go
something like this right quantum is all
about taking advantage of accounts of
cancellations if i look at this tensor
network there's no there everything is
non-negative there are no cancellations
in this thing none whatsoever so quantum
can't shouldn't be able to help us on
this okay so that's that's the heuristic
argument that says surely you can do
this classically which is some sort of
sampling it should be fine right the
funny thing is that I haven't been able
to do it that's not funny but a lot of
other people haven't been able to do it
though I can't quite tell their their
interests their interests change once
their first idea doesn't seem to quite
work but but the the important curiosity
about this thing is that the level of
approximation quantumly has to do with
operator norm okay operator norm of
these tensors if you think of most like
sampling ideas classical sampling ideas
it has to do with l1 norm it has to do
with you know you sort of right you sort
of make it a stochastic
ty playing you do then you do so so you
would extort of naively you would say
where's that connection right because
classically naively somewhat ever going
to be popping out is l1 norm quantumly
what's popping out is l2 norm we know
that there are plenty of examples where
those aren't the same thing right you
view a tensor and you look at it saw one
Norman and sell to norm not the same
thing and l2 norm is better and so how
are we going to kind of use a classical
thing that that that does it so I'm
there are plenty of people who know more
about sampling than I do and I'm hoping
one of them is here and can do this
problem because i'm tired of musing
about it ok that's it thank you question
they need to get a better there feel for
approximation you want here so again
it's a little bit delicate if you scale
if you're just asking informations been
asking for meaningful answers you really
have to tune this to be pounding away
from zero site and you can feel for
where the heart
it's a good question i don't really know
I just don't know any I just if I first
got everybody down by a didn't they
trivialize the problem so in the quantum
case it's clear what the right scaling
is no I so let's play maybe let's uh
perhaps what I do is I sort of give you
a quarter of the bubbling with the
requirement that these linear maps in
that ordering our norm one now the
scaling is fine we're just let the deal
to her yeah and I'm pretty good a
helpful as an answering
add another quick question to you open a
lock that circuits you said okay you can
simulate it classically bubbling the
thing from left to right another way we
know to go to persecute you could have
our MPs for the starting state and I
just go down straight down and updates
that MPs as you apply a weekend and your
that up because you're only going along
times you'd end up with a vital signs
MPs at the end of the circuit and there
will be another scheduled to do a
referring how they found you know
there's cases where you could imagine
where the one with you much worse with
the other however I say yeah yeah so
good maybe is that maybe sort of thought
as a then eventually you have to then
eventually do the MPS you have to sweep
this way that just sort of maybe before
the ultimate contraction I mean if
you're just interested in starting 0 and
computing the overlap and 0 at the end
then you get an mps with the end of the
circle identities then you do the feud
over happens while y'all shouldn't that
way you have to do the end is I mean
there's no escaping having a joke well
you think over a little products state
so it's you're just plugging in 0 0
which would ya yes or no I don't know
how to you can imagine that one
direction so the bond dimension would be
cheaper you know when the other would
know
yeah where you actually really good
still get again yeah sorry i haven't
done that you can forecast yeah but you
have a negative models and you have a
cellular automata consider particles
kind of moving freely you're contracting
on directing attention network well you
here okay in that particular case both
of them are polynomials but I guess okay
one of them could be much better than
putting your same buddies any other
questions
all right let's take this we have a
coffee break in to resume at seven